[Music]  starting tonight I am running for the  President of the United States  absolutely I'd vote for him I just want  to talk to him when he's in the Oval  Office and just shoot it and see what  life's like being the president yeah see  what the gym turns out like not only  with my vote he promised me a cabinet  position he's so conscientious such a  great guy has such leadership qualities  why not I actually think that Dwayne  would make a great president he's very  honest he's very genuine and he really  cares about people I would be very  tempted to vote for him because I adore  him he can count on my vote the first  favor I'm going to ask for is a sit-down  with his vice president Tom Hanks I  guess we got to do it come on  [Music]  [Applause]  you